[Musique]
mais déjà dans l'ambiance de la
guignolée du dr julien c'est la 16e
aujourd'hui et comme chaque année c'est
une grande collecte permet de recueillir
des fonds pour offrir des soins
directement aux enfants en situation de
grande vulnérabilité qui fréquentent les
centres de pédiatrie sociale créée par
dr gilles julien qui est avec moi ce
matin docteur julien bonjour au grand
plaisir de vous recevoir
de même vous êtes aviez pour les grands
froids ouais il fait chaud thé chap mais
savait toujours la conséquence c'est une
première qui face à ces choses que ça on
va en profiter aujourd'hui et c'est une
journée très spéciale pour vous c'est la
journée de l'année pour la fondation aux
états unis où absolument c'est pour nous
le sait c'est un peu notre bulletin
annuel comme je répète à chaque année
c'est vraiment l'appui de la population
qu'on recherche pour aider les enfants
les plus vulnérables parce qu on le fait
dans les communautés donc on s'attend à
ce que les communautés participe aussi
avec les centres de pédiatrie sociale
financière mais vous nous raconter
l'histoire d'un enfant qui reçoit de
l'aide de la fondation
oui j'ai une belle histoire justement
son jeune fils kim ki moon a rendu à 24
ans mais qui qui était avec moi depuis
les tout débuts avec l'équipe puis on la
compagnie beaucoup beaucoup puis
beaucoup de bord plus que de hauts
mais on savait qu'elle avait le
potentiel va absolument on est bons
retrouver le potentiel des enfants pour
pouvoir fonctionner là dessus et pour
pour faire une histoire courte finale
elle a évolué très bien plus vieille
elle m'a bien mature et finalement avec
beaucoup de virages de toutes sortes de
beaumont était toujours là avec elle et
finalement se retrouve à lettres aux
enfants et enceinte d'un quatrième et le
passé proche de perdre des premiers que
la dpj mais finalement assez remis en
piste
elle est même devenu maintenant une
famille d'accueil pour un autre enfant
deux familles éloignées reconnu par la
dpj c'est ça c'est vraiment le type de
belles histoires qu'on a régulièrement
parce qu'on est là toujours sur la
trajectoire des enfants on les
accompagne
si des crises ils viennent nous voir ton
fait partie de la famille sociale que
vous offrez avec votre approche de
pédiatrie sociale à un enfant plus vous
le suivez pendant des années où on est
toujours le moi particulièrement parce
que j'ai assez le doyenné maintenant
mais il ya toujours une constance que
quelqu'un qui vole il y est d'ailleurs
se voir qui va analyser la demande qui
va trouver des solutions toujours avec
eux à l'immobiliser jamais on tire on va
le faire pour toi ou on veut envoyer à
telle place parce que ça fonctionne pas
alors c'est l'idée de la communauté le
qui prend soin de ses enfants qu'on
essaie de déplacer partout en fait au
québec est maintenant 1 34 centres au
québec qui font ce type de médecine
sociale et c'est une cause qui touche
beaucoup de monde l'an dernier vous avez
amassé environ 7 1 millions $
à quoi sert cet argent là qui est donnée
par le public parce que vous avez aussi
de l'argent des entreprises et du
gouvernement mais les fonds qui viennent
du public servi front populaire le king
qui sont downing pour les guignols et
pour nous ça va directement services
directs aux enfers se dit ça va servir
cette jeune mère qui m'a appelé hier
qu'ils étaient en peine parce que ils
n'ont plus rien à manger est pas capable
d'avoir de paniers de noël dans les
systèmes donc on voit la dépanner on va
dépanner un enfant qui ont mobilisé une
enfant plutôt qu' un rêve qui veut
réaliser puis ça beau tout va mal dans
sa vie s'il veut jouer à qui on va le
faire joueur ok parce que ça va la mener
plus loin que ça va nous permettre
d'agir sur les autres niveaux et c'est
beaucoup de service intensif aussi pour
les problématiques de développement
comportement de troubles d'apprentissage
de droits d'enfants bafouée aussi alors
on est toujours là comme ça et l'argent
de la guignolée vient vraiment sur cette
partie là qui représentent à peu près le
tiers du budget et ça se passe à trois
endroits principalement à montréal au
centre de pédiatrie hochelaga
maisonneuve côte des neiges au garage à
musique également d'autres points de
service à travers le québec tout à fait
les centres intérieurs au québec font
leur guignery il faut les encourager ils
sont dans une communauté qui a des
besoins aussi et pour nous mais les
trois centres sont ouverts pour la
première fois avant c'était à udine h
les gars maintenant on peut aller
directement voir les enfants des
familles pile du puy voir ce qui se
passe pour vrai dans ces trois lieux de
julian merci d'avoir été là le remercie
beaucoup ce que vous faites pour nos
enfants
guignol et ce plaisir mais c'était avant